cette entreprise familiale de grand
sault qui compte une trentaine
d'employés rêve de percer le marché du
pipeline
le projet énergie est de transcanada lui
offrirait une occasion en or de le faire
une dizaine d'années déjà concours d'un
alberto pour aussi l'entrée d'un dab
raisonnement pour l'énergie fait le
connaît un projet c'est nous encore plus
intéressant transcanada veut construire
un oléoduc de 12 milliards de dollars
pour transporter le pétrole de l'ouest
du canada jusqu'à la raffinerie de saint
jean au nouveau brunswick
ici le projet reçoit un meilleur accueil
qu au québec
l'élément qui fait pencher la balance en
sa faveur au nouveau brunswick la
création d'emplois durant la phase de
construction
transcanada prévoit créer environ 2000
emplois par année durant 7 ans et cet
argument suffi pour que plusieurs élus
appuyé le projet
le premier ministre du nouveau-brunswick
apparaît même dans une vidéo
promotionnelle de transcanada le maire
de grand sault aussi a pu héberger
richard kelly se trouve dans une
position délicate car il est aussi le
directeur régional du ministère de
l'environnement pour la province
d'ailleurs c'est désormais le maire
adjoint qui accorde les entrevues au
sujet du pipeline ont ouvert à l'heure
actuelle nos jeunes gens s'en aller dans
l'ouest canadien pourrait aller
travailler
on a peut être une chance d'un repas
terrier plusieurs d'eux disons que ça a
pas été chose facile d'appuyer un projet
semblable parce qu'on sait qu'ils
parlent r d dans les mets ont saisi
après longue discussion avec un grand
soin n'était pas là pour juger de la
sécurité un peu plus au nord la ville
d'edmundston elle n'a pas utilisé cette
stratégie les premiers tracés de
transcanada passé en plein quartier
résidentiel les citoyens s'y sont
opposés et la pétrolière a modifié ses
plans au c'est clair que quand c'est
plus proche de notre cour les citoyens
sont sont davantage préoccupés en fait
il est difficile de trouver des néo
brunswickois qui sont contre le pipeline
et qui ose le dire publiquement
s'opposer à un projet créateur d'emplois
est mal vu les terres en ahl tout de
suite ce sens jacques moret a tout de
même
accepté de nous parler il craint de voir
le lieu d'une traversée ses terres on se
sent envahir date à l'heure actuelle dix
comme qui vont pas aussi loin si tu
devrais side story on ne sait plus
jacques moret et ses voisins ne sont pas
tout à fait contre l'oléoduc
ils sont surtout contre le fait de
l'avoir dans leur cour on veut juste pas
voici nos terres c'est aussi qu'ils
seraient loin assez on se sentirait plus
en sécurité avec notre eau potable
le projet d'oléoduc n'a pas encore vu
jour que la promesse d'emploi fait déjà
rêver de nombreux néo brunswickois
éclipse d'autres considérations ici
marilyn marceau radio-canada durs au
monde